let's bring in Peter Schrager here big
introduction for Peter Peter co-hosts
NFL Network's good morning football
Monday through Friday at 7:00 Eastern
foxsports.com senior national writer
he's a popular guy you'll see him on the
sidelines and of course you know in
studio NFL Network good morning football
you still have makeup on from today ten
years ago I know I used to borrow my
wife's makeup because when I first
started at ESPN they didn't have a
makeup artist okay so Keith and I that
famous you know
SportsCenter commercial we're putting on
our makeup and every night before we
went on we would go into the bathroom
like somebody could be in the stall but
we're there putting on our makeup before
we go on and I had no idea what I was
doing no I'm like did you go to like the
Macy's makeup counter and say like can
you assist me yes yes I did with my wife
I would borrow her makeup but now we
have makeup art well I can only imagine
the Bristol men's room it must have been
a wonderful singing yeah yeah there were
a lot of senses there like I'm putting
on my make because they said we couldn't
afford a makeup more amazing think of
how far ESPN has come think about that
oh boy
alright jaylen Ramsey's trade value is
what ha there's the problem he wants to
be the highest-paid cornerback in
football so everyone says well if Minka
Fitzpatrick is worth a first-round pick
why wouldn't he because it's almost like
Khalil Mac last year where it's not just
the player you also have to break the
bank and completely shatter your salary
cap this one's in midseason so I think
they're gonna want a couple first-round
picks whatever it is but truth the
matter is he's not as valuable a trade
asset because of what he's gonna want on
the back end so you're hearing a lot of
teams that's fine
I think what's about right is a first
and a third and then they're gonna have
to crack out a deal for him to make that
salary that he wants it's a really tough
spot for the team to deal with now as
opposed to in July or August if you were
gonna bet where he's gonna be next week
where would you say I think he can get
traded tomorrow like that's honestly I
feel like that's how these trade rumors
are bubbling on my phone and all that
stuff but to give you a destination it's
going to be a contending team or a team
looking to make
splash though contending team your usual
teams that are aggressive now the
Patriots the Ravens the Eagles they're
always getting making phone calls and
then there's the wildcard teams that
need to make a splash
I still think the Raiders might want to
make a splash and Jalen Ramsey coming to
Vegas could be quite a splash yeah
that's the that's what I was told
yesterday that you know they're sort of
the Dark Horse you know keep keep the
Raiders on your radar there but also if
you're Jacksonville
can you play him tonight and trade him
tomorrow and it weird first of all the
league rules say you can't play two
games in one week so whoever he trades
whoever he is traded to if he is traded
can't play on Sunday so you already
aren't getting them this week if you
play them secondarily what if he gets
hurt and I know quarter I know or what
if he says you know what I don't want to
be a Jaguar and let's a touchdown the
first quart like I don't know what
psychologically is going on right now
between the coaching staff and John
Ramsey Doug Marrone was on the record
saying now now we're good like you don't
understand that's a relationship ain't
good they're not good so what are you
getting from him and then also the risk
of injury it's a surprising decision to
say no matter what he's playing
considering what's going on in the week
why do I get the feeling that people
want to pile on this Cam Newton
situation that this isn't the beginning
of the end this is the end for some
people like the the opinions that I've
read and heard that all of a sudden Cam
Newton is the artist formerly known as
that's a great take it's almost like
he's cooked if he can't do what he did
in 2015 and I want nothing of Cam Newton
at all to tell you right now on a
Thursday I'd be surprised if I saw him
under Center on Sunday against Arizona
but what about the rest of the year
because is it a foot injury a back
injury a shoulder injury or is this that
Cam Newton you know everyone has the
second chapter in his career this can't
even have that second chapter I saw Paul
Finebaum was very definitive right on
ESPN saying he's done I wouldn't say
that as far as that this guy's played
football his entire life I think he's
actually a pretty smart quarterback too
he can play football game but he
probably can't play it at that MVP level
all right
Kansas City and the Ravens awesome right
yeah like who would have thought like
which quarterback will be more
productive if I said who accounts for
more touchdowns between Lamar Jackson
and Patrick mahomes on Sunday yeah
that's a week you take because the X
Factor is the Ravens defense is really
good I did the sidelines for
Cardinals Raven so I got to do a
production meeting with Lamar Jackson
and speak with Harbaugh and all those
coaches Greg Roman the unknown here is
how much those Ravens players and
coaches trust Lamar Jackson to the point
they love this guy it's almost like it's
us versus the world everyone thinks he's
a running back everyone's think we're
gonna show you and we're gonna
overcompensate for that and make sure
he's has a put in position to be
successful and that defenses Rouen St
like the Ravens defense is nasty last
year they played the Chiefs in Arrowhead
and mahomes had the no-look pass yeah we
talked he didn't have a great day
like mahomes played well in the fourth
quarter but they bottled him up and
they've got that certain swagger I would
be surprised if my Holmes did the usual
350 four touchdowns against this Ravens
defense and yet the Chiefs defense
leaves a lot to be desired
I could see Lamar having a bit of a day
I could see Lamar having a better
offensive statistical line then Patrick
Holmes even in Kansas City okay but are
you buying if large action to stock you
buying that stock long-term or 20 1983
honestly I don't know if he could stay
upright the way that they play it with
him everyone says oh look told you he's
not around he runs the ball last week he
had about five different scampers where
he puts himself in harm's way eventually
one of those hits is gonna cause what
we're seeing with other running
quarterbacks you've seen it too many
times new but right now my buying stock
in Lamar Jackson yes you didn't sound
too convincing there yeah we were
recording on that well of course it's
not gonna change over the next couple of
weeks but I want to see how this
defensive coordinators are smart they
can read the things that they see on
film in the first couple of weeks he's
played against Arizona in Miami so let's
see what he does against Kansas City and
then of course when the big boys in the
AFC come rolling in an NFC let's see how
the Moore does explain the timing of the
Giants benching Eli even though they
have bigger problems than Eli in the
quarterbacking position they rip the
band-aid off it's very surprising
because I talked to those guys in that
building I talked to everyone loved
Daniel Jones all summer but the plan was
Eli Eli Eli Kansas City model all that
stuff and then I think honestly there's
no buzz around the Giants whatsoever
they're the most irrelevant team in New
Yorker
now even the Jets are getting more pub
they lost two games to two teams that
one of them blew him out the other one
you know was just as easy in the home
game I think it's all right let's start
the future now but am I surprised yes I
would have said week eight or nine was
the over-under regardless of how eli
played but they pulled the shoot already
do you think an antonio brown plays the
entire season for the patriot i do i do
in unless the NFL puts that on ice but I
don't think the Patriots are backing off
on this thing he's a really good player
they've already put him on the team
unless they find out information that
makes them feel like it's an untenable
situation I think the Patriots are all
in on this Antonio Brown and they all
the stuff that came out this past week
Sports Illustrated article that was very
inflammatory they're full steam ahead I
had somebody who as a source with the
league who said you know he joked he
said the patriot way is to look the
other way
like is this are we surprised with
anything here or is there culpability
with the Patriots there have been a lot
of situations with the Patriots and
players on that roster where things have
happened off the field and the Patriots
later said you know hey I don't know you
know we that were focused on football
this one here all the writing was on the
wall going in everyone told you that now
the obvious allegations and what's going
on in the league office right now I
think was a bit of a surprise for them
but this was not a model teammate the
last 12 months and it might not have
been a model citizen either Peter
Schrager from good morning football NFL
Network joining us Barry Zito by the way
he was caught astok he was great
he really was gotta bring it back it's
amazing yeah yeah you know and then you
got a good-looking guy who can also play
guitar I mean that's not fair no any win
just i yelling world series awesome
how did she how did she react when I
asked about Alyssa Milano and Jennifer
Love Hewitt
yeah the Nashville music scene amber
well I know when I asked the question
and then I all of a sudden cease eating
out of the corner of my eye like going
well I gotta ask him and then it led to
the most powerful part of the
conversation is he was going to these LA
clubs finding trying to find his
identity by dating somebody famous so if
people go all berries
he dating somebody famous there I hate
to derail our Peter Schrager interview I
said I do football shows Barry plays
fantasy football and Barry Zito will
criticize the players and I'll say Barry
you're doing the same exact thing upset
with Daniel Jones is performing that was
funny
dak Prescott is still unpaid I know but
it's pretty good he's doing the smart
thing isn't he Joe Flacco did it a
couple years ago and I said that you
know all summer I'm like there's no rush
for him if he feels satisfied off the
field financially and thinks that he can
bet on himself he's gonna get the
biggest contract more than he would have
made in August and there's been a
bubbling sense of optimism all summer do
despite all the drama with the Cowboys
that Kellen Moore is the DAK whisperer
and that Kellen Moore who finished third
in the Heisman - - Cam Newton and Andrew
Luck is now the greatest offensive
coordinator to ever touch the feet but
he's getting the most out of dak dak
spit looked good the last two weeks he's
probably looked better the last two
weeks I've ever seen him before they
play that dolphins this week every week
he's just stacking chips in his corner
but they might ride this out all season
yeah but you know what help helps a
young quarterback a great offensive line
and unbelievable running backs
Frederick's pretty good wet weapons if I
put dak Prescott in Tennessee we're not
talking about dak Prescott it's fair
it's the right place right time and I do
like him I I think he's better than what
people have you know because he's not a
first-round pick and I think we're you
know we get to be draft elitist like
where were you direct home no it's true
I think people took a couple Russell
Wilson we're still yeah we're coming
around it saying how great he is I think
people still are skeptical and Brady
even after he won that Super Bowl it was
okay let's see now that there's a book
on him mahomes it was a first-round pick
but he was the third quarterback taken
so people still think second quarter
that all right well because true Biscay
went before my home's true Biscay will
be as good as my home's no the Holmes is
a rare deal but you're right there's a
bias with all these guys and with dak
Prescott when you see Connor cook was
taken before and all these other names
are taken before him say well we
couldn't have messed up the draft
process that right like there's some
there's got to be some gimmick that said
there's you could only drive the car
that you're driven and he was driven a
car that Romo got hurt Kellen Moore got
hurt
then he was the guy and he hasn't given
up that quarterback job since what do
you think of the Dolphins strategy I
hate it and I'll tell you why I hate it
I don't hate the fact that they're
saying we're looking towards the future
Minka Fitzpatrick was a top 15 pick one
of the best safeties to come out of
college in recent history a great kid
all around on the second year of a
rookie deal I don't know the messages
you're saying we're saying even that guy
is expendable for another first-round
pick know what no matter what you get in
that draft it's very hard to be as good
a prospect as Minka was so he's proven
he's proven after one year and he is on
a second year of a five-year deal so
whatever you're getting is it better
than Minka Fitzpatrick whether he wanted
to be there or not
furthermore it's one thing to trade off
35 year old veterans 22 year old
safeties sure they can do it I don't get
the philosophy I don't get the strategy
I understand that you're gonna tank for
two oh that's fine they are historically
bad if they lose by more than 15 points
it is the greatest point differential
through three weeks in NFL history and
that's not what anyone wants that's not
a fair product to the fans are you sold
I'm not sold on tour and I'm not sold on
Lawrence I'm just not I know how this
goes you know we've had quarterbacks who
have emerged and you go oh my god Matt
Barkley is unbelievable you just wait
yeah the Penn State kid Christian
Hackenberg like we want to anoint we're
so quick to anoint and then I'm just not
sure when I you know Lawrence doesn't
look as good this year as he did last
year
I like to uh but Jalen Hertz is putting
up unbelievable numbers I don't know the
Lincoln Riley sister yes so you're like
wait a second if Tyler's doing that and
Baker's doing that maybe a sure and you
know are you sold on to a it's very
difficult for me to be sold for anyone
under six feet who's lefty in the NFL
and there's not a single lefty
quarterback in the league it's a very
unorthodox looking quarterback and yet
the guy wins he makes plays with his
feet and the way the NFL is moving to us
seems like he's the prototypical next
yeah but he's got it he's got all-pro
wide receivers in Alabama they've always
got a great offensive line and they've
always got a very good running back and
you've got an unbelievable coach right
as coach yeah in cultural history so
it's hard for me to assess how a long
history of Alabama quarterback
years no Paulie yes Dan the i-team has a
report is Peter Schrager commented he
said the Miami Dolphins they're fans
they deserve better I heard out of the
back row and I don't think it was pretty
oh god you don't like that take that
frame you guys are so soft if you're
gonna do the process you got to do the
process no half measures you can't not
do the individual you telling me you
wouldn't have done the Laremy Tunsil
trade or you guys wouldn't have done the
Minka Fitzpatrick tons was 25 mega
Fitzpatrick's 22 it's one thing they're
highway robbery both deals are gonna go
down as absolute steals look Sachi brown
you know might have gotten a lot of pics
but when they the first-round picks were
just in Gilbert and Johnny mins doesn't
always work out like it took years for
the Browns to get that draft class and
even then in joke who's on Pervin and
we'll see what happens with your bro
peppers I guess to me I'd rather have
players and talent over picks in the NFL
that's different I feel like you walk
through that door it's the same thing I
said about the Browns it's one thing to
have picks it's another thing to do
something with those picks I don't know
how good Miami is it drafting people you
know they got like it's Patrick and they
got Tunstall will you give him credit
for drafting those guys I know but I
want to know when you know you're
drafting a quarterback that's gonna make
or break you if you spend this capital
and you're gonna spend that number one
overall pick and and otua is not what we
think he is but what if the Steelers
attending shank again to get Trevor
Lawrence the following year what if what
if the Steelers end up being bad and
they need a quarterback and they trade
it for a safety that will go down as
like a Cleveland Cavaliers of the 80s
movie I was surprised that the Steelers
got but I think they're they're
confident in Mason Rudolph that guy yeah
it's impossible the Dolphins knew
something new Tunsil better than the
other team's draft wasn't exactly a
great moment for him I would say one
thing on the Dolphins they don't do any
of this how many times you've been
caught with a bong mask on those
I mean a handful but not on a Thursday
night honestly though the Dolphins made
all these trades the first two weeks of
September to me if they did it in April
or May I would sit to the fans okay so
don't go buy that Jersey or don't go buy
you know don't get to me that's where I
feel for the fans it's like we bought
the merchandise we got the season
tickets we already booked our travel and
now you're going to do all this and
start the fire sale I just felt like it
was kind of a rough deal for dolphins it
would have been nice if they'd let him
in and just said hey we're gonna cut
prices because we have an inferior
product out here we're all in this
together I would have been fun
Peter Schrager you can see him every
morning Monday through Friday at 7:00
a.m. Eastern co-host even though there's
four people you're the lead host come on
okay he's the lead host that's not true
he's the lead host of NFL network's you
don't want chaos panic you know you do
not I don't anything mad at me good yeah
but um Kyle Brent you're not afraid of
softies pretty boy come on oh yeah it's
great to see you great to see Barry Zito
yeah for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]